I'm Richard bacon let's talk about
surveillance but let's do it quietly
because they're probably listening that
thing in your pocket that you call a
smartphone it's a tracking device that
just happens to make calls digital
tracking has become a part of our
everyday lives it is how we answer our
biggest questions one of those cute
shoes going on sale what happened to
that cute girl on you in high school
where's that cute commander of Isis
that's right the same technology that
targets terrorists is also being used to
sell you Halloween costumes for your dog
you're probably aware that companies are
collecting your data but you don't know
the half of it
let's run the numbers 1500 that is how
many pieces of information data company
axiom has on every single consumer in
the United States 1500 if you asked me
for 10 interesting pieces of information
about myself I'd struggle axiom bundles
your information into profiles with
catchy names like men in trouble
and then sells them to advertisers men
in trouble is a file made up of married
men who've recently searched for flowers
and chocolates in trouble
91 researchers at the University of
Pennsylvania found that when you look up
medic this is amazing when you look at
medical symptoms online 91% of those
websites are sharing your searches with
third parties even shipping the
information directly to the same brokers
who monitor your credit scores in other
words everybody knows about your weird
rash
300 according to a recent study it takes
just 300 Facebook likes for big data to
know you better than your spouse the
algorithms used by Facebook are so good
they can predict your sexual preference
with up to 88 percent accuracy which
means Mark Zuckerberg knows you're gay
before you do 0 that is the amount of
messages that you have deleted in your
life there may be a delete button but
there's no such thing as delete apps
track every key that you push you can
find anything you want online except for
privacy and those were the numbers
Oh